[Music]
coming to you from his house in los
angeles it's Conan he's broken
I'm Andy Richter tonight jesse eisenberg
[Music]
[Applause]
hello there and welcome to show number
three this is our third show which is
why I said number three I'm repeating
myself losing it quickly here I think we
all are just a little bit these are
strange times but we forge ahead we have
a wonderful program tonight we're gonna
be joined by one of my favorite people
Jesse Eisenberg I'm leaning forward to
show you how much I admire and respect
Jesse Eisenberg he's gonna be joining us
terrific actor and also I want to point
out once again I am broadcasting from my
home in Los Angeles this is my little
kooky study I found something just
minutes before we started broadcasting
meaning minutes before I pushed play on
my iPhone look at this this is a
microphone that was given to me back in
my NBC days and I've treasured it and
I've had it here in my study ever since
isn't that cool look at that thing it's
a plane flying overhead can you hear
that plane paparazzi anyway I'm amusing
myself and that's what we've pretty much
sunk to this a cool little microphone I
just love having this around it gives me
sort of a an old-timey look yes yes big
news flash there's been a fire at
McCready's barn
it was set by Hitler all forces to
McCready's barn it was always a fire at
macri's barn that was the only news they
had back then and anything bad was
started by Hitler that's all in the 30s
and 40s anyway just sharing with you
little little pieces of my world so much
to discuss
everyone's getting through this
kookiness the best that they can one
thing I've noticed is many people out
there are baking
that seems to be a big thing happening
right now people are baking and they're
posting they're processed their recipes
and their results and I want to be part
of this just like everyone else
so I tried my hand at it a little
earlier today take a look everybody is
baking right now it makes sense we're
all quarantined it's a good way to be
together takes your mind off your
troubles
it's very nourishing I love baking and
I'm pretty good at it I will tell you
that so what I did is late yesterday I
decided to make some bread I looked up a
good recipe on the Internet I made
myself some dough got into a nice ball
put it in a bowl and I covered it with a
wet cloth that's important put it on the
windowsill let it sit overnight this
morning I got up set the oven to 350
degrees popped it in the whole house
right now smells like fresh baked bread
that's the best part
and now comes the moment when I get my
bread out oh and that's hot that's hot
don't get too close okay
that's beautiful it's a golden brown as
I used sort of a egg white to glaze the
top also while I was at it I made these
flaming hot cheeto pups and I painted
all that a little with a cheetah right
there I also made this I had some
plastic leftover so I made some
strawberry syrup
I just put the burches logo on it myself
because why not
and then finally I made this Lego
replica I baked it up overnight of a
Land Rover Defender it's an exact scale
model ready to eat overnight
you can make so much joy